الحرب على المخدرات عنوان امتلات به منصات
التواصل والحسابات الرسميه وغيرها الرسميه
في السعوديه حيث تخوض المملكه حربا دروسا
شكلت تجربه فريده من نوعها في محاربه كل
من يتاجر بالمخدرات ويروج لها ويتعاطا
اطلقت حملات متعدده من بلغ عنهم وبالمرصاد
وخل القريب وغيرها من الحملات داخل
السعوديه والتي طالبت خلالها المجتمع
المحلي بالاشتراك فيها والتعاون مع
السلطات المعنيه راينا كيف تم ادراج حرب
السعوديه على المخدرات ايضا ضمن الاعمال
الدراميه في الموسم الرمضاني والتي
شهدناها في احدى حلقات المسلسل الشهير طاش
العوده والتي تناولت خطر المخدرات على
حياه الشباب والتي لقد تفاعلا منقطع
النظير امس انتشر مقطع فيديو للفنان فايز
المالكي تم تداوله بشكل واسع جدا
ظهر فيه وهو يتكلم عن خطر المخدرات وقال
انها هلاك وضيع وتدمير للفرد والمجتمع
وطالب كل من يرى مدمنا ومروجا للمخدرات
الابلاغ عنه مباشره
يا جماعه
شيء معادي ترى معاني
هذه هذه قسما بالله جماعه هلاك ضياع اللي
ياكل منها لا يتوقع انه يوم من الايام ولا
دكتور ولا ضابط ولا مسؤول في المجتمع ولا
عرف هذا المجتمع حيصير
والله لا يمسك بالكلام ولا باي شيء اللي
شفته واحد اللي شايفينه اليوم واحد في
البيت فيه
[موسيقى]
الينا عبر الزوم من القسيمه البروفيسور
يوسف الاستاذ المشارك في مكافحه الجريمه
بروفيسور اهلا بكم معنا في تفاعلكم وفي
العربيه اولا نبدا بالحديث هل كان متوقعا
حجم هذا التفاعل الكبير مع حجم الحمله
القويه لمكافحه المخدرات داخل السعوديه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله نعم بلا هذه الحمله
اتت على عده محاور
محور الشرعي بالخطباء
في المدارس محور الامني ولاحظنا حالات
القفز كثيره جدا على مهربي ومروج المخدرات
ايضا المحور التوعوي مع الاسر مع الاحيان
مع الانديه الى اخره فاتت هذه الحمله بعده
محاور لتكون شامله باذن الله لتقضي على
هذا الوباء وفعلا بدات تؤتي اكلها طيب
بالحديث عن عده محاور ابرز هذه المحاور تم
تركيز هذه المره على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اهميه تركيز الحمله على مواقع
التواصل
لمتابعه وملاحقه المروجين للمخدرات
والمتاجرين بها خص
وصا لانه
التجار المخدرات ومروج المخدرات في المقام
الاول الشباب الشباب الصغار هؤلاء الشباب
سلاحهم الاول او طريقتهم الاهم والاكثر
حساسيه
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه من هنا اتت هذه
الحمله لتحاول ان تقضي على هذا على هذا
هذا الفساد وتحاول ان بدل ما يكون سلاح ضد
شبابنا يكون سلاح
لشبابنا ضد
المخدرات
لذلك من المهم جدا التعامل مع وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لتكون ايجابيه لتكون
مساعده بدل من كونها سلبيه لان ثبت ان
ارباب المخدرات يستغلونها للتواصل مع
الشباب من هنا من المهم جدا ان الاهل
الامنيين ايضا اهل التوعيه الفكريه
الصحيحه يستخدمون هذا السلاح لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي للوصول الى شريحه
الشباب هذه هي الطريقه الاكثر الان شفنا
الفيديو للفنان فايز المالكي والتوعيه
التي
قام بها من خلال هذا الفيديو اهميه
التوعيه اهميه الشراكه المجتمع المحلي
والاسره في هذا الجانب
الكريم للاسف الشديد التوعيه من من اهم من
اهم وسائل الوقايه من المخدرات الملاحظ ان
بعض الاسر تعيش في عالم اخر عن شبابها عن
ابنائها عن بنائها لذلك من المهم جدا
توعيه الاسر من عده طرق من الطريق الشرعي
من الطريقه الامني
الجهه الامنيه تعرض ايضا من وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه للوصول الى الاسره لتوعيه
الاسره لان الاسره هي خط الدفاع الاول ضد
المخدرات
لذلك مهم جدا ان نعي الاسر
لان الاسره هي اول
ما اكثر او اسرع من من المدرسه من المسجد
من ايضا من الجهه الامنيه الام والاب هم
الاسرع والاخوه هم الاسرع عنده ملاحظه ان
هذا الشاب او هذا الشابه بدات في مراحل
الدخول في المخدرات او في عالم الادمان
لذلك من المهم ان نواعيهم النصر الى الى
هذه الاسر الى ارباب الاسر الاباء الامهات
الاخوه الاخوات
وننبهم على خطر هذه الخطيره جدا طب اللي
لفتني اضافه بروفيسور الى مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ادراج هذه الحمله والحرب ضد
المخدرات على الاعمال او الى الاعمال
الدراميه التي يحبها الجمهور كما شفناها
في طاش العوده اهميه ذلك
باستقطاب الشباب
نعم هناك عدد من من الشباب والشابات
والاسر
الكبار السن تلعب الدراما لهم دور رئيسي
ودور مهم عندما تلقي المعلومه اكثر من
الرساله التوعيه احيانا تكون جافه
الدراما تلعب تلعب على على على الاحاسيس
على المشاعر على العواطف وتؤتي اكلها بشكل
جيد الحمد لله لذلك مهم جدا استغلال جميع
الوسائل مثل ما هو ارباب المخدرات
يستخدمون الان جميع الوسائل يجب ان نستخدم
جميع الوسائل لمنعها وضرب اماكنها وضرب
ايضا مروجيها ومهربيها بحيث نصل الى كل
شرائح المجتمع
شكرا جزيلا لك من القصيم حتى البروفيسور
يوسف الرميح الاستاذ المشارك في مكافحه
الجريمه شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]